CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is here she was
homeland security and counterterrorism
adviser to President George W Bush we
are also joined by CBS News law
enforcement analyst Paul Biola's who's
had a long career in law enforcement and
security Paul and friend welcome back to
both of you and unfortunately Paul as we
heard from the Clark County Sheriff Joe
Lombardo visibly shaken when he
delivered the latest news he is stealing
everyone for worse news to come all
right unfortunately and I kudos - to Las
Vegas PD and in their containment in the
expeditious manner in which they've
responded to this but you know when the
sheriff speaking about that it's safe to
say for him to come out and say that
there's 50 and the amount of injured
unfortunately that number is probably
gonna go up this is now being called the
deadliest mass shooting in American
history what will they now be looking
for Paul perimeter they're gonna have to
they're establishing an inner perimeter
and an outer perimeter for where the
concert was this - crime scene scale
then you also have the crime scene where
the shooter wasn't 32nd floor the
Mandalay Bay they're gonna have to look
at and they're going to use the casings
that were dropped and they're going to
see the weapons that he used and
hopefully they're going to find more
physical evidence in that particular
location that's going to give them a
further further information as to what
their next steps are and who they need
to interview let's talk about that
friend he's on the 32nd floor I mean
this is this seems to be something we
haven't seen before in this country we
had talked to an eyewitness that said
your bags were checked as you went into
the arena it was an outdoor festival but
somebody on the 32nd floor that just
sprays and was there for a long period
of time that's right look we've heard
from eyewitness reports that the
shooting went on anywhere from 8 to 15
minutes that sounds like an incredibly
long period of time if you're in that
Plaza right and you're hearing the shots
but the fact that the Las Vegas police
department and SWAT team could identify
the source of the fire get up to that
room breach that room and take out the
shooter in that period of time is really
incredible it's it's a credit to them
the you know the Las Vegas Sheriff's
Office works very closely with the
hotels in Las Vegas the chief security
officers meet on a regular basis they do
they perform exercises with the local
sheriff's department
and all those things were to the benefit
in resolving this and as horrific as the
numbers are and I agree with Paul
they're likely to rise it would have
been much worse if the Las Vegas law
enforcement had not responded to so
you're giving a lot of credit to them
exactly what to do but that's exactly
they train in this that's right and they
practice just these sorts of scenarios
so that they know they've looked at the
blueprints of the hotels and they've
worked through so they know exactly what
they're doing when they enter that room
to take this guy out and Fran the White
House chief of staff John Kelly was the
one who alerted the president of the
shooting the president tweeting my
warmest condolences and sympathies to
the victims and families of the terrible
Las Vegas shooting god bless you no word
yet on whether this will officially turn
into a federal investigation but do you
expect that to happen
certainly that the feds will support it
right so things like the ATF alcohol
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms is
essential to understanding the history
of each of the weapons you know we know
that it was an automatic weapon that the
shooter used we also know from the
Clarke clan sheriff that they found
other weapons in the room you're gonna
want to know the entire history of those
weapons when did he purchase them from
where and that will be an important
piece and so the feds will help that it
depends on theirs we know that there's a
search warrant at his mesquite
retirement home the shooters they will
go through all of his electronics they
will go through physical evidence they
will try to understand what the motive
is we don't know that yet but many of
the clues to that will exist in the
physical evidence as well as an
interview of the wife or companion that
they now have identified and spoken this
is the woman Mary Lou Dan Lee who who is
his wife
Steven paddocks wife who they were
looking for all morning long they sent
out Las Vegas police tweeted out a
picture of her look at saying they were
wanted to speak with her we do not know
where she is now or what condition she
is in but we do know that police have
said they have located her which is the
primary person they were trying to reach
after this shooting happened to figure
out what happened yeah it'll be
interesting to hear the circumstances of
how she was in custody Fran Townsend and
Paul violas you'll be with us all
morning so of course we'll get back to
you in just a second